today in nation protests are up across
the country again for the second time in
a month a grand jury has decided not to
indict a white police officer for
killing an unarmed black man
a white new york city police officer
accused of killing a black man with a
choke hold is not indicted protests
broke out after the grand jury decided
not again not to indict the officer
garner was killed with a chokehold while
he was being arrested for allegedly
selling untaxed
cigarettes video of eric garner's arrest
and choke hold went viral this is the
video from back in july the officer
performing the maneuvers police officer
danielle pantaleo at one point you can
hear garner tell the officers that he
can't breathe
chokeholds have been banned by the
police department since a 1990s 1993 and
medical examiner ruled the death of
garner a homicide
officer pandolio told the staten island
grand jury that he did not intend to
choke garner and didn't think garner was
in mortal danger pantaleo released this
statement quote i feel very bad about
the death of mr garner my family and i
include him and his family and our
prayers and i hope that they will accept
my personal condolences for their loss
well the apology won him little sympathy
among protesters here is eric garner's
widow
there's nothing that him
or his friends or anything else would
make me feel any different no i don't
accept his apology no i can care
just two weeks ago a grand jury declined
to indict a police officer in the death
of unarmed teen michael
brown in ferguson in mississippi in both
cases the victims were black and the
officers were white bringing the
conversation of racial inequality to the
forefront of national discussion here's
the response from president obama
it is incumbent about all of us as
americans regardless of race
region
faith
that we recognize this is an american
problem and not just a black problem or
a brown problem or
a native american problem this is an
american problem when anybody in this
country is not being treated equally
under the law
that's a problem
and it's my job as president to help
solve it